2018 has already delivered a number of
standout horror movies many of them
flying under the radar of most
moviegoers so we've collected our
favorites in this list making it easier
than ever to find gold in this
ever-growing content heap subtlety and
style don't often rule the box-office
particularly when it comes to genre fare
the horror landscape has been frequently
dominated by in-your-face slashers
squeamish torture marathons and gritty
found-footage outings it can come as a
pleasant surprise then when a movie gets
enough of a budget for some striking
visuals while remaining quiet enough to
leave you with lingering questions and a
genuine sense of unease Alex Garland an
author and screenwriter who made his
directorial debut with the 2015 sci-fi
sleeper hit ex machina returned in 2018
with annihilation hailed by critics with
praises like heady nightmare fuel
garland sophomore effort definitely
blends a metaphor laced space invasion
story with creeping dread and uncanny
imagery though it was a financial
disappointment in theaters word of mouth
has only continued to build around
annihilation since its home video
release its big ideas and its cast the
fan favorite actors ensure that it will
continue to be discovered by audiences
for years to come humor and horror
frequently rely on a similar set of
tools for surprising the audience and
lately comedy superstars are making that
leap with gusto Jordan peels expertise
in satirical sketches brought and get
out to terrify in life and eastbound and
down creators Danny McBride and David
Gordon Green blended their penchant for
slapstick with real scare power for
Halloween between those two crossovers
the office star John Krasinski made an
impressive turn as director co-writer
and star of a quiet place perhaps it was
his nine seasons enduring painfully
awkward pauses at dunder-mifflin that
prepared Krasinski to pull off the
harrowing tension of a quiet place our
prices have never been the movie
captured the attention of audiences and
critics when it crept into theaters in
April with its clever premise and
minimalist presentation that leaves much
to the imagination it's tiny cast is
rounded out with a stellar performance
by Emily Blunt newcomer Noah Juke and
young deaf actress Millicent Simmons who
made sure that the film's portrayal of
life were a family with a
F child remained authentic many of the
best horror films reflect the cultural
tenor of their time extrapolating new
technologies or societal shifts into
speculative tales of Terror even stories
that seem conceptually downright silly
can tap into frightening lis real
anxieties that are on the audience's
mind or will be in the near future such
as the case with upgrade a schlocky bid
a body horror that plays on the moral
questions surrounding artificial
intelligence and billionaire tech
entrepreneurs in the not-too-distant
future where computer assisted body
modification is the norm a mechanic
named Perret remains staunchly defensive
of his own humanity refusing to become
augmented that is until a malfunction by
a self-driving car leaves his wife dead
in himself wheelchair-bound enter tech
innovator Aaron Kean who offers to
restore Gray's motor functions with his
newest AI chip as any horror aficionado
could guess this melding of man and
machine has some gruesome results
directed by Leigh Whannell of saw Fame
and produced by genre juggernaut Blum
house upgrade blends topical concerns
with an old-fashioned sense of gritty
grindhouse fun I need your permission to
operate independently
[Music]
surprisingly receptive critics have also
praised its sharp humor and tight
plotting horror anthologies have a long
and storied history across a variety of
media movies have had mixed success with
the format though as getting audiences
to sit still for two hours of short
stories can be a challenge after the
1980s saw the release of the cult
favorite Creepshow and the infamously
disastrous Twilight Zone the movie
horror anthology films went mostly
dormant until recent years when tricker
treats and the VHS series became
Halloween staples in 2018 American
audiences were treated to an import of a
new British horror anthology ghost
stories the project began its life as a
stage play by Andy diamond and Jeremy
Dyson who adapted it into a film
starring Neyman Paul Whitehouse and
Martin Freeman the story follows a
professor known for debunking hoaxes as
he investigates three cases of alleged
paranormal activity the lines between
reality and fiction blur as the
anthology builds to a startling Lisa
real climax all of which earned largely
positive reviews zombies and vampires
may have had recent moments in the Sun
but werewolves are a monster vein that
remains largely untapped in current pop
culture that only adds to the joy and
watching as wildling slowly reveals it's
supernatural elements while weaving a
smart and sympathetic character study
like most classic tales of lupine
transformation it's a coming-of-age
story designed to do for young women of
today what Ginger Snaps did in 2000
changer the future debut from director
Fritz Boehm wildling is buoyed by
performances from genre favorites Liv
Tyler and Brad Dourif best known to
horror hounds as the voice of Chucky
Belle pally takes the lead as Anna a
teenage girl who's rescued by the local
sheriff after growing up under the
abusive thumb of a father figure who
claimed to be protecting her from
man-eating creatures outside wildling
has been hailed by critics for its
powerhouse performances and striking
visuals The Hollywood Reporter listed it
as one of the 10 best films debuting at
South by Southwest and it's definitely
one of the best horror films of 2018
Netflix has spent the last few years
ramping up their output of original
content and the results have been mixed
to say the least
breed from the need to sell tickets and
relying largely on word-of-mouth for
publicity the streaming platforms
release strategies have created a new
arena of risks and surprises or every
pop culture smash like stranger things
there's a misguided bizzle like
disjointed for every big-budget
disappointment like brights there's a
hidden gem like cargo with the glut of
zombie fare over the past decade it's
understandable that a drama about The
Walking Dead might get lost in the
shuffle and shamble cargo however brings
some fresh brains to the sub-genre with
a quiet story about one family's post
outbreak life in rural Australia
directed by the filmmaking team of Ben
howling in yolanda ramp key and anchored
by an understated but intense
performance by Martin Freeman cargo was
favorably compared by critics to the
works of George a Romero and John Hill
code a 24 has established itself as a
distributor of movies by up-and-coming
filmmakers who are ready to balance
nuanced stories with stylish visuals all
on a small budget their greatest success
to date is probably berry Jenkins Best
Picture winner moonlight but they also
secured a place in the hearts of horror
fans with the witch and it comes at
night and they continued that hot streak
in 2018 with another low-key creep fest
hereditary the feature debut from writer
director Arie Astor hereditary sets out
to unnerve you with a cornucopia of
disturbing omens bizarre visuals and
surreal nightmare logic critics
immediately got behind it in a big way
heaping particular praise on the lead
performance by Toni Collette
interestingly hereditary seems to have
caused a
polarizing split between critics and
audiences as evidenced by the wide gap
between its critic and audience scores
at Rotten Tomatoes
regardless it's been a smashing success
at the box office having already made
back its budget several times over
everyone who buys a ticket to a Nicholas
Cage vehicle knows to expect something
bonkers even that won't prepare you for
Mandy a surreal experience and sound
color and vengeance the entire cast
turned in mesmerizing performances in
the second film from director Panos
cosmatos set in the early 1980s
Mandy is the story of a man taking
violent revenge against the religious
cult and the supernatural forces allied
with them but recounting the plot of
Mandy doesn't really tell you anything
about why it works on paper it's a
fairly cliched revenge story but Cosmo
doses style elevates the movie to a
mythic hypnotic level the movie builds
to a fevered climax immersing us in its
hero's heavy metal and fantasy novel
inspired world view really nothing we
could say here would explain why critics
loved Mandy you're just gonna have to
experience it for yourself the word
risky doesn't often apply to
long-running franchises but 2018 s
Halloween had no right to be as
successful as it was though masked
murderer Michael Myers remains a
towering horror icon John Carpenter's
1978 original is the only movie in the
series to hold unquestioned classic
status it's for decade run has been rife
with multiple retcons reboots and a
general sense of diminishing returns
from eastbound and downs Danny McBride
and David Gordon Green the newest
iteration of Halloween had a troubled
road of its own but fans interest was
peaked when Carpenter came on board as
producer and composer the hype
intensified when Jamie Lee Curtis signed
on to reprise her star-making role as
Laurie Strode things were shaping up but
with a writer and director team more
versed in comedy than horror it was
still hard to guess what we were in for
what we got was a lean thrilling sequel
that eschewed complicated slasher lore
in favor of a story about time and
trauma rather than put Michael front and
center the movie makes his killing spree
the backdrop to Laurie's fractured
relationships with her daughter and
granddaughter when the shape does strike
though he's as clever and brutal as ever
audiences and critics got behind the
revival in a big way proving that this
Halloween was at last a worthy six
- its legendary namesake with JJ Abrams
bad robot production company behind it
audiences could be forgiven for
suspecting that overlord might turn out
to be a stealth Cloverfield movie even
when Abrams denied the connection during
the film's production it still seemed
like yet another bit of deception it
wasn't though Overlord isn't a
Cloverfield movie no really it does
however have a traditional Abram style
mashup of human drama with supernatural
horror the movie follows a platoon of
Allied soldiers in world war ii who
encounter a Nazi laboratory full of
horrifying creatures critics appreciated
its skilled blend of war movie and
horror movie tropes with one reviewer
comparing overlord favorably to Night of
the Living Dead and declaring it a
future cult classic horror remakes don't
often achieve prestige status but that
certainly happened in 2018 with Suspiria
call me by your name director luca
guadagnino completely reimagined Dario
Argento's 1977 cult favorite twisting
its bones into a deep meditation on
themes like identity manipulation loss
and rebellion it even threads the very
idea of being a remake into its own
story as dance students Uzi is slowly
and irreversibly changed by her efforts
to follow in the footsteps of her
enigmatic instructor Madame Blanc the
response to Guadagnino film has been
nothing short to polarize a glance at
Rotten Tomatoes reveals a critical
opinion resting comfortably in the
middle percentages unlike many films was
such a lukewarm average though Suspiria
landed there because of a hard split
between individual reviewers people
either loved it or very much did not a
discerning crowd at Khan Film Festival
gave its premiere a rousing ovation but
there's no shortage of critics quite
literally calling it garbage Suspiria
may well be either a horror fans
favorite or least favorite film of 2018
but the passionate reaction it's
inspired certainly suggests it won't be
forgotten anytime soon